[Musica]
vorrei provare a disegnare la tua faccia
è come togliere una
ma da una roccia vorrei provare ad
abitare nei tuoi occhi per poi sognare
finché siamo salvi
il retro
su questo link
ma se mi guardi
indici che
[Musica]
non rassegnare
una vita perfetta e voi la mia
7 che vuoi la mia
maglietta
[Musica]
siamo
vorrei provare a fare la tua faccia
gente
ci vuole
[Musica]
cerchiamo
adesso
[Musica]
vorrei la tua bellezza
[Applauso]
[Musica]
come mai sono venuto stasera bella
domanda
se dicessi che mi manca il tuo cane ci
crederesti un vicino tutto tranne che il
sun nella triste una spin in gola che mi
fa male fa male dammi un'altra domanda
che non riesco a parlare
quel che vorrei dirti stasera è
importante solo che a guardarti negli
occhi mi ci perde quando il chelsea
lezioso minelli che dentro grassi di
dormire con te non toccati candy candy
ma certo vuoi dormire colca del sé
quanta gente ci fisica di ci parla come
gli esseri umani intanto i giorni che
passano accanto e di partire come treni
che non hanno i binari ali di carte
quanti inutili scemi restano su facebook
si credono geni
parla il caso mentre non ci lasciamo di
noi piangiamo poi dormiamo cliccare ti
sei accorta anche tu siamo tutti più
soli
tipo il numero 10 sulla schiena e poi
sbagliando
ti sei accorta anche tu in questo mondo
lo dirò e nessuno uguale essere robben
[Musica]
[Applauso]